[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno como pueden ver cuando nosotros
hablamos de boxeo lo primero que nos
viene a la cabeza es algo como lo que
están viendo ahí ah no
el boxeo es
para gente que quizás viene de un
estrato bajo o gente que no piensa
cierto pero si lo vemos más a fondo pues
yo lo veo de esta manera porque porque
si nosotros vemos este deporte pues el
boxeo es algo que que es un deporte que
forma persona
hoy en día me formaba me formaba muchos
deportistas boxeo es para gente
inteligente cierto porque porque
nosotros como boxeadores nosotros no
simplemente
vamos a salir a tirar por golpes no
nosotros siempre vamos a estar pensando
como pueden ver este deporte es algo que
no simplemente trata de
de junio de edad y toma y daca no
no simplemente 'toma y daca' como pueden
ver nosotros nos preparamos tanto física
como mentalmente en la parte física
nosotros trabajamos lo que es la técnica
trabajamos la fuerza la potencia en la
parte mental ya nosotros trabajamos con
lo que son psicólogos
está conformado perdón por el psicólogo
médico fisioterapeuta y nutricionista
son aquellas personas que siempre están
detrás de nosotros porque muchas veces
ven en el deportista y ese no es bueno
pero no ven el equipo de trabajo hoy en
día lo que ha hecho el profe mío rafael
en nada y la verdad que tengo mucho que
agradecerle a él porque de una manera
siempre nos ha enseñado principios nos
ha enseñado valores y eso es lo que lo
que se debe hacer hoy en día ha tratado
con un método de entrenamiento que
siempre
lo que más trabajamos era la fuerza la
física entonces el profesor hoy en día
ya no metió a trabajar con lo que es
psicólogo
bueno
y cuando subo al ring se imaginan
ustedes qué pasa cuando yo subo un ring
dice no va a pelear
pero claro ese es el fuerte salimos a
pelear pero yo cuando subo a un ring lo
primero que yo hago
pero no me subo ni entro por donde entra
todo el mundo porque ustedes ven que
ustedes se imaginarán un ring con una
puerta imagínense en un rincón una
puerta para una entrada
váccaro no
pero no lloro cuando es cuando sube la
escalera lo primero que hago es caminar
el ring para que para darme cuenta cómo
está la lona ya está yo aplico la del
burro cuando sale la de burro
qué hace un burro un grupo cuando tenía
por un caminito el cetro pieza y cuando
se tropieza para que tú lo vuelvas a
meter por ahí es un problema
entonces yo aplicó la misma yo camino el
ring tocó el tocó este lado a no está
bien por ahí me como meter voy lleva las
chinas recibo mi instrucciones profe me
dice sanos y beta yo llego y me tiro a
una esquina me tiro a la otra y pero eso
fuera estrategia va a tratar entonces
hago la en burro
para el medio ambiente
y allá subí al ring me siento bien me
siento concentrado entonces yo digo
bueno ese soy yo
como pueden ver aquí está el río que
pasa cuando cuando ustedes ven un ring
que pasa lo único que ven son cuatro
esquinas cierto nosotros los buceadores
no nosotros vemos mucho más allá porque
porque nosotros
el ring lo volvemos un círculo más o
menos algo así
un círculo porque porque nosotros es una
estrategia básica que tenemos todos
nosotros como como boxeadores hay tipos
de boxeadores hay que saber que pelean a
la larga
mediana y corta distancia yo soy un
museo que peleo a la corta distancia
pues porque me gusta candela la caldera
queríamos la corta distancia nos
encontramos con enunciados que tenía la
larga distancia lo primero que hacemos o
tratamos de hacer es llevarlo a la
esquina para que no se pueda mover
porque porque está en la esquina cierto
entonces cuando nosotros lo encerramos
en la esquina o sea le cortamos el paso
y cortamos el paso lo metemos a la
esquina ya sabemos que si es bajo rep
acá se encuentra con una puerta cierto
si corre para acá se encuentra con la
otra y si da el paso hacia atrás se
encuentra con el esquinero y si quiere
salir hacia adelante bueno ya ustedes
saben qué va a pasar
entonces es
cosa de negociadores entonces cuando
nosotros empezamos a competir y eso
nosotros no nos entusiasmamos o bien si
nosotros empezamos a pensar y empezamos
a crear estrategia empezamos a a
a decirlo bueno hoy le voy a hacer esto
el proyecto a x posee ahora porque
nosotros cuando estamos en una
competencia nosotros no nos preparamos
para un solo voceador sino que nos
preparamos para varios boxeadores
boxeadores zurdos hay boxeadores que son
derechos que son diestros entonces ya
nosotros tenemos que armarnos una
película pues por decirlo así
viene el profe te te plantea una
estrategia pero tú tienes que tener la
capacidad de que si esa estrategia no te
sale en el ring tienes que tener la
voluntad de poder cambiar esa estrategia
porque nosotros los como decía ahora eso
somos los que decimos
si el profe me dice tírales ya yo le
estoy tirando ya cuántos saben que
muchas
bueno poquito les voy a aplicar el golpe
uno tira con la mano adelante le llaman
busquen un golpe rápido y si yo tiro el
yang y el otro meta contra golpeando y
el profe me dice que le tire ya yo no
voy para tirar
está golpeando me está golpeando o sea
inteligencia pura de boxeo
así
en el golpe y golpe y golpe
nosotros como decía ahora vemos el boxeo
de esa manera
sí
porque puede ser así que hay que
estudiar como les decía anteriormente
hay que estudiar hay que estudiar aquí a
tu oponente a tu enemigo tiene que
aprender a conocerlo porque si no lo
conoces cómo hacer para para
contrarrestar sus sus debilidades para
ese perdón sus fortalezas como va a ser
para saber cuáles son sus debilidades
tenemos que estudiar si muchas personas
dirán a los luchadores son juntos y
ahora soy para mí para mí los boxeadores
son las personas más inteligentes que
hay en el mundo
hablamos de boxeo yo lo único que puedo
comparar en este deporte es como como el
ajedrez saben por qué
porque nosotros como este ahora tenemos
que anticipar a nuestro enemigo
porque cuando nosotros viene un ataque
ya nosotros tenemos que hacerle una
defensa y un ataque a él
a ese golpe que el enemigo nos lanza así
que bueno yo no sé jugaba ajedrez
pues aparentemente porque él sí lo ha
jugado sí lo es jugar y lo he jugado en
este deporte porque este deporte para
personas que saben mover las fichas
eso eso me recuerda mi primera técnica
mi primera táctica
es útil pasa que yo cuando inicié este
deporte lo inicié gracias a un compañero
que estábamos estudiando y él llega ahí
se me secaba diversity
hemos entrenado deseo yo no es a mí no
me gusta a mí de gm en mi béisbol porque
a mí antes me gustaba el béisbol y
entonces él me decía yo pero es que
entonces que hace bueno yo lo además mi
papás son cristianos entonces no
entonces mi compañero me decía you were
van con uno hasta que un día yo día
vamos a no este tipo de encima
y fui él hizo un sparring joey bacán
cuando sabe que un sparring
bueno un sparring es como un simulacro
de una pelea si un ensayo entonces yo
llegué y lo ubique en su espacio y
pasada los wolves y trufas bien bacán
entonces yo ya y así y así el médico y
vt quiere ponerlo cuántico bueno vale
ese es mi guante
yo como no sabía luego como bravas y
callejeros así
entonces algo así y cuando te toque
esto no es lo mismo y me fui
y entonces llega al compañero y me dice
pero you es uno trate de un golpe ni
nada ven mañana yendo
entonces llegué y me fui me fui para la
casa y me acosté y me puse a pensar esté
más beca está burlando
eso no se queda así señor eso no se
puede quedar así entonces salí en eso
llegó un proceso
de antonio mendoza y entonces llegó y yo
le dije profesional se me dio así bueno
yo voy a dar clases de boxeo entonces yo
les aproxime va a enseñar sigo y si no
no hablen de una vez que ya no se diga
que yo le voy a enseñar técnica y como
bueno una de esas técnicas que me enseñó
fue la pura pura defensa al golpe la
mano adelante entonces yo llegué así
aprendí yo iba por la calle y de una
ramita yo
la goma entonces después me enseñó lo
que en contraataques aman lo que mi
primera técnica fue él y me tiró en ella
yo hacía
y esto
benito wow yo todo ya todos los días yo
no éramos
entonces llegué yo así
un viernes recuerdo que procede que no
va a ser fácil y entonces es con él
con una estatura y con ellos y con ese
apoyo eres más grande que tú te llamas
pepsi yo no profesores con él si no no
no voy a bojan ha bajado de los profes
lo convencía bueno y entonces viene
el profe y luego nos pasa si estás salud
de semana nos saludamos vos y cuando yo
llego porque yo sabía más o menos
entonces llegué y me paré así cuando me
paré así la primera mano que me lanza
ella joan y javi perdiste
pero yo cerré los ojos y cuando abro los
ojos imagines uruguay
se pincharon
pero la parte más dura hablar con mi
papá
porque yo llegué a hablar con mi papá de
hablar con mi papá y entonces
yo quiero entrenar imagínate para que
estén entrenando boxeo y papá antes
alguien soy yo yo claro mi papá
y aquí hablando con ustedes va a pasar y
entonces yo le digo que está entrenando
boxeo y hay una salida para decir tú me
das permiso y va con ellos que no te vea
bueno como todo niño bueno ya
entonces cogí y seguí entrenando hasta
el día mi papá
entrenando hasta que ya empecé a meter
lo que es la mano derecha y todo gancho
cruzado y me perfeccioné llegue
nuevamente otra salida para imagínate
que yo tiene entrenando boxeo
y lo que habíamos hablado la vez pasada
y yo le diga
usted siempre quiere que yo haga lo que
usted y lo que usted quiere que haga y
no me dejas en mi vida no pago y eso es
lo que a mí me gusta y entonces
y rafa si nuevo mismo pero era un pastor
y no como el hijo de facto por ahí
tirando otros pagos
y entonces yo le di a verdad que es un
pastor
venga acabado
usted sabe quién es david y me dijo si
yo sé quién es david guetta que no un
pastor de antes y después de ser un
pastor ya no fue un gran rey johan un
rey para ti
antes de ser rey el transcurso para
llegar a ser rey que fue algo que fue un
guerrero que no yagüe
quien quita quita debate quita que a
través de esto yo me esté elaborando un
camino para ello ser un guerrero de dios
yo sí
y ella sabe que sabe que en el tiempo de
antes no peleándose van trompa ni nada
será más etc
yo le dije que yo me voy o me voy
empaque y franja cuando empatas y nos
fuimos casi a mi primera un primer
combate y allá de sambito dragon ball z
bueno ahí yo me la cráneo y empecé aquí
a pensar para ustedes que es más rápido
la mente o el hombro
hoy ya nada murmura
bueno más rápido en la mente porque
porque la mente
el ojo se canta como 5 segundos para
captar una imagen en cambio que el
cerebro procesa la imagen y manda de una
vez reacciones
de movimiento y eso es cierto bueno
entonces
yo pensé rapidito una vez blanco y así
mismo pensamos nosotros los boxeadores
nosotros contadores tenemos que
reaccionar en milésimas de segundo así
así así pasa todo de mí cuando me tiran
un ya uno de ustedes le hago tres
movimientos de una vez
porque se ríe
este es uno de los personajes que más me
inspiran porque
un super saiyan y que fuerte más fuerte
de todo y a pesar de todo eso a pesar de
que es más fuerte sigue entrenando para
que para cumplir con sus metas u
objetivos sí así que yo me veo
representado mucho en goku
así que los ámbitos
bueno así que con todo eso gracias
muchas gracias
[Música]
así que gracias a que he sido un
boxeador que pelea con la cabeza y no
con los golpes ella obtener uno más
grandes logros muchas gracias
[Aplausos]